[Musique]
salut l'intérieur salut les terriens ce
soir en p1 nous accueillons stéphane
hessel
n'est pas le seul bon soir
bon choix vous êtes l'auteur du
phénomène littéraire de ces deux
dernières années votre livre indignez
vous s'est vendu à 4 millions
d'exemplaires dans le monde
et c'est pas fini c'est vrai que c'est
arrivé au stade où finissez par être
vous même indignée du succès de votre
livre
absolument en tous les cas bravo hein
en p2 nous accueillerons jean vincent
placé
jean vincent placé
président du comité de campagne d'eva
joly nous dira s'il est encore sûr de
voter pour elle
toujours en p2 nous accueillerons jason
jason comédienne et humoriste pour son
spectacle où elle raconte le drame
d'avoir eu des parents soixante huitards
qui s'appelle sous les pavés les pavés
enfin en p3 après le zapping et guillon
nous accueillerons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir caroline poiron
car une fois en photographe et compagne
de gilles jacquier le grand reporter de
france 2 tué le 11 janvier dernier en
syrie voilà l'émission s'appelle salut
les terriens et le groupe les gréements
le ventoux
[Musique]
stéphane hessel re bonsoir
avait 94 ans et vous battez ce soir le
record de l'invité le plus âgé de
l'émission bravo bravo
c'est un record qui était détenu jusque
là par edgar morin qui est votre ami oui
et michel galabru voilà un big up
[Applaudissements]
alors stéphane nous allons commencer par
parler de votre vie mais vu votre âge je
crois qu'on va faire un petit résumé
vous m'en voulez pas oui oh là soyez
bref alors vous êtes né à berlin le 20
octobre 1917 père juif homme de lettres
qui traduira proust et nabokov proche du
champ de man ray mère protestante
luthérienne issu d'une famille de
banquiers en très antisémite mais qui
ont reconnu que mon père bien que juive
était un excellent mari pour ses valeurs
alors votre maire partagera sa vie entre
votre père est l'écrivain pierre henri
roché dont le roman jules et jim sera
portée à l'écran par françois truffaut
mais oui le petit garçon que j'étais n'a
rien compris à tout ce qui se passait
j'avais 3 ans 1 mais par la suite le
fait d'avoir une mère qui soit une
personnalité très forte très libre très
moderne a joué naturellement un rôle
considère un sua roma formation au
rocher aussi a joué un rôle considérable
dans votre vie baisse de 2 deuxième père
il vous permettra de fréquenter
l'intelligentzia de l'époque c'était un
proche de guillaume apollinaire par
exemple qui pour moi reste le poète mais
bon poète favori bac à 15 ans ensuite de
brillantes études supérieures fait
normale sup en 1939 c'est l'armée vous
est fait prisonnier et vous vous évader
pour rejoindre de gaulle à londres en
1941 vous dites c'est un engagement qui
dépasse la morale classique vous méfier
de la la moraline en fait de nietzsche
et qui fait d'être différence entre ce
qui est légal et ce qui est légitime et
quelquefois ce qui est légal n'est pas
léger bravo j'adore alors ensuite bon
bah c'est la résistance vous êtes arrêté
en 1944 vous êtes déporté à buchenwald
où vous échapperait à la pendaison à un
croc de boucher grâce à une substitution
d'identité avec un détenu mort du typhus
un dénommé boitel michel boitel qui
reste une un poids sur ma conscience il
est mort et grâce à sa mort j'ai survécu
faut porter alors ensuite j'ai été
envoyé à doha où les nazis fabriquées
leur fameuse fusée qui devait détruire
londres les v1 et v2 vous évader et vous
rejoignez l'armée américaine là vous
entrez dans la diplomatie et en 1946 est
à new york où vous assistez à la
rédaction de la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme aux nations unies
et si sur les valeurs de ce texte sur
celle du conseil national de la
résistance que vous fondre et vos
engagements d'après guerre et qui
inspireront votre incroyable best-seller
indignez-vous traduit en 33 langues
vendu à 4 millions d'exemplaires dans le
monde vous êtes quand même le français
qui a vendu le plus de livres au monde
en 2011 quand même ben voilà mieux que
marc levy c'est le fait que nous soyons
tombés juste nous avons parlé
d'indignation à un monde il n'était pas
satisfait de la manière dont ils étaient
conduits et qui avait donc des raisons
de dire on veut pas de ça au sein d'ibm
alors vous dites l'indignation est le
ferment de l'esprit de résistance je
pense que le mot résistance est un mot
précieux qui signifie qu on ne peut pas
accepter le monde tel qu'il est il y a
toujours quelque chose d'inacceptable et
qui mérite qu'on se manifeste qu'on
s'indigne
ouais il faut dire aux gens de résister
parce qu'aujourd'hui les gens résistent
peu sauf quand il faut prendre du
dessert quoi en général
alors grâce à vous a été instauré le
samedi 15 octobre dernier la journée
mondiale des indignés
enfin faut quand même relativiser parce
que c'est également la journée mondiale
du lavage de mains vous saviez sa
commencions par vous l'avait dépeint et
ensuite on s'indignera ce qui ne va pas
dans la boue c'est véridique alors
qu'est-ce qui vous indigne en ce moment
où ses fans la façon dont nous avons
traité en france les immigrés
quand on essaye de faire le départ entre
ceux qui seraient de vrais bons français
et puis s'il rêve pas de vraiment bon
français mais qu'il faut quand même
accepté chez nous alors c'est la fin
est-ce que les gens qui disent par
contre au lieu de dire en revanche c'est
ce que ça vous indigne ça et pas
vraiment mais vous avez raison de nous
mettre sur cette voie la façon dont on
parle la façon dont on s'exprime surtout
quand on occupe une fonction importante
au gouvernement faut faire attention
casse toi pauvre con par exemple bah oui
j'étais un bon exemple est ce que vous
êtes indignés par le livre de goldnadel
qui vous accusent d'avoir enjolivé votre
passé de résistant ah non mais je trouve
heureux d'avoir quelqu'un qui me
traitent de vieillards indique que ça ça
me fait plaisir quand il s'agit de
quelqu'un pour lequel je ne peut avoir
aucune aucun respect parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui dit n'importe quoi il va
pas de main morte il dit vous avez
exagéré votre participation à la
rédaction de la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme de l'onu et puis
ce qui les énerve le plus en fait c'est
que vous focalisez souvent vos critiques
contre l'état d'israël ça il ne supporte
pas mais oui mais je le comprends je
sais que les israéliens sont très
sensibles il se considère comme la seule
démocratie du proche orient alors qu'ils
ne sont ni démocrates ni respectueux du
droit international on ne peut pas
accepter que des palestiniens soient
traités comme ils l'ont été tout au long
de ces quarante dernières années et
notamment à gaza lorsque c'est affreux
opération plomb durci a été menée par le
gouvernement israélien ça je ne lui
pardonne pas alors goldnadel dit en
parlant de vous s'imagine que vous le
savez stéphane hessel c'est l'abbé
pierre - la soutane à réprimer me vante
un effet une soulte à si vous en avez
[Applaudissements]
tes fans cette semaine est sorti votre
nouveau livre publié chez don quichotte
et intitulé le rescapé et l'exil est
alors le rescapé évidemment c'est vous
et l'exil et c'est elias sanbar
représentant de la palestine à l'unesco
alors vous dialoguez tous les deux sur
israël et la palestine vous poser la
question est ce que c'était vraiment là
en palestine qu'il fallait installer ce
foyer national c'était un effet une
question qu'on pouvait se poser nous
savions qu'il y avait des arabes et des
chrétiens d'ailleurs et des juifs déjà
qu'ils vivaient la valette il donnait
cher là aux juifs qui sortait de
l'horreur de la shoah et bien finalement
j'ai pensé qu'on a bien fait je pense
que jérusalem pour eux est un endroit
qui n'a pas de comparaison le dossier
madagascar il y avait des idées mais
aucune ne valait ce retour des juifs
dans une terre qui leur était tellement
cher vous dites que plus dramatique
c'est qu'à l'époque nous ne pensions pas
qu'il existait un peuple palestinien
nous pensions qu'il y avait des arabes
et que ces arabes disposer d'un vaste
territoire vous avez pris conscience en
fait de l'existence du peuple
palestinien en 1967
ces chats à partir du moment où israël
gagnant une guerre et au lieu d'en tirer
une conséquence en dix ans maintenant
notre sécurité a assuré
nous allons travailler avec nos voisins
et leur donner un état ils ont au
contraire occupé d'abord colonisé
ensuite oui vous dites on a vraiment
pris conscience qu'il existait un peuple
palestinien qu'il avait une patrie la
palestine où il vivait depuis fort
longtemps et d'où ils avaient été
chassés par une armée moderne et
violente exactement alors finalement ce
sont la guerre et le terrorisme qui vous
ont fait prendre conscience de la
réalité palestinienne d'une certaine
façon le peuple israélien est un peuple
pour lequel j'ai beaucoup d'affection
mais qu'ils se soient laissés dirigés
par des gouvernements
fasciste je le dis tout clairement et
qui font de l'occupation et de la
colonisation
ça me révolte un agaza il n'y avait déjà
plus de colons israéliens ils sont été
retiré mais là dessus il ya eu un
mouvement hamas violent je ne reconnais
violent agressif qui a envoyé des
rockets mais au lieu d'essayer de faire
la paix avec lui on l'a envahie avec une
opération qu'on appelait plomb durci et
qui a fait plus de 1400 victimes en
l'espace de trois semaines est grave ou
dit en parlant des palestiniens la
violence est totalement légitime quand
le faible n'a pas d'autre moyen de
résister à l'oppression et vous comparez
en fait la violence des des palestiniens
à celle des résistants français contre
les nazis il n'y a rien eu au monde de
plus épouvantable que ce que nous
appelons la shoah c'est à dire la façon
dont les juifs d'europe ont été
exterminés par les nazis il reste que
lorsque une pays un gouvernement se
comporte bizarrerie de ces bois sein
d'une façon brutale d'une façon sans
aucun respect pour leurs droits
fondamentaux
eh bien on a affaire à quelque chose qui
nous rappellent la façon dont nous
français avons été traités par nos
envahisseurs allemands ouais donc la
violence légitime quand il ya violence
il faut répondre alors il faut essayer
dé répondre par la non violence ni un
exemple admirable nous est donnée ces
temps ci ou ça
puis la grande birmane prix nobel
nos violent de bout en bout pas une
action bien là et maintenant elle finit
par avoir son mot à dire pour l'avenir
de son pays gandhi a libéré l'un d'eux
sans violence exactement alors est ce
que pour finir cette interview vous
pourriez me dire un petit poème aux mets
volontiers un petit apollinaire par
exemple un peu court quand je commence à
réciter mes enfants me disent papa on
veut bien pour aimer course
alors je vous propose celui qu'il
appelait l'automne dans le brouillard
s'en vont un paysan khâgneux et son
boeuf lentement dans le brouillard
d'automne qui cache les hameaux pauvres
et berg au lieu et ce en allant là-bas
le paysan chantonne une chanson d'amour
et d'infidélité qui parle d'une bad et
d'un coeur que l'on brise à l'automne
notons a fait mourir l'été dans le
brouillard sans bons de silhouette grise
hu bravo seulement
voilà c'était la pire des insultes et on
se doit après la pub avec jean vincent
placé
jason pour discuter avec nous de la
qualité de la chevalerie match
renonçant luthérienne roman sur le
terrain nous sommes toujours en
compagnie de stéphane hessel
et nous accueillons jean vincent placé
et jason
alors jean vincent placé bonsoir vous
êtes sénateur europe ecologie les verts
de l'essonne europe ecologie les verts
mais j'arrive pas à me faire à trouver
des noms c'est pas son truc à duflot a
appelé sa fille térébenthine
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas appeler ça le
bio partie par exemple soit et rigolo
bref moi j'ai fait pour que ça s'appelle
tout simplement le parti écologiste et
ben voila voila
mais oui le parti vous n'auriez appeler
ou chou alias aurait marché vous auriez
fait 10 % de plus alors jean vincent
vous êtes également président du comité
de campagne d'eva joly et vous êtes ici
ce soir pour répondre à la question que
tout le monde se pose est ce que vous
n'auriez pas fait une connerie en
prenant eva joly comme candidate
au contraire j'étais avec elle à
montpellier mercredi dernier et on a
fait un super meeting il y avait il y
avait du monde et puis voilà nous on
voit bien que c'est difficile mais le
temps de crise économique et sociale ne
met pas les idées des écologistes en
avant en appoint qui sont de la planète
les questions de ressources naturelles
et depuis quand n'avez jamais entendu
parler et moi ça me désole jean vincent
c'est peut-être le problème de la
candidate parce que faire des primaires
pour en arriver là si ça continue je
vous dirais y aura plus de gens qui ont
voté pour eva joly au primaire qu'au
présidentielle
de 3% ouais à la présidentielle ça doit
faire un peu plus sur ses fers 3% on est
à ça nous on espère arriver à cinq six
mois et deux là ont fait campagne pour
être embauché vous faire 5% oui oui je
n'y est pas ou 5% qu'est ce qui vous
reste comme solution pour faire remonter
la cote de popularité d'eva joly à part
la campagne ne pas se présenter
evans il reste heureusement ouvrir enfin
les yeux de nos compatriotes dans un car
leur aveuglement est scandaleux et
criminels
nous avons besoin d d'écologie nous
allons avoir dans quelques mois rio +20
points grande conférence mondiale qui va
nous faire apparaître une fois de plus à
quel point nous sommes mal barrés pour
cette planète eh bien il est temps que
les querelles j europe ecologie les
verts ou ou bravo mais
également l'arrivée 1
dites moi je rassemble c'est toujours le
numéro de cohn bendit
mais non avec daniel cohn bendit on
partage beaucoup de choses sur été hulot
comme bendit aurait peut-être été des
candidats plus puissant pour porter
votre message j'en suis pas sûr eva
joli d'autres qualités elle a un
parcours extraordinaire de juge
d'instruction elle a démontré cette
honnêteté
inflexible avoir fait ses preuves avoir
de la conviction avoir été la cité c'est
pas rien c'est évidemment peut-être que
dans le fond la politique spectacle
qu'on nous impose parfois avait pris
dans les émissions populaires mais vous
voyez bien est-ce que bien mieux parler
rapidement avec deux trois formules etc
mais c'est pas ça qui fait navire en
séquences vidéo d'alcon et maintenant
j'en un sens c'est à dire quoi on en
arriver au stade où c'est pas le
nucléaire qui fait peur c'est eva joly
justement justement c'est très
intéressant ce que vous dites là parce
qu'être malgré tout moi j'ai vu que
depuis 3 4 ans et notamment grâce à
daniel cohn bendit et impulsion qu'il a
donné aux européennes les idées des
écologistes ont été davantage entendue à
1go dernières élections notamment les
grands lobbys industriels économiques
ils voient bien que nous progressons
dans la société les écologistes ont
encore à manque de crédibilité par
rapport à l'exercice je pensais
responsabilité du pouvoir notamment
niveau national il ya un truc chambre à
l'année dernière cécile duflot a déclaré
qu'elle n'avait pas les épaules assez
larges pour se présenter est ce que vous
pensez sincèrement qu eva joly a les
épaules assez larges pour se présenter
in g pour faire une candidature
symbolique aux dépens d'un panda ou une
loutre de rivière
j'ai vu qu'il y avait deux rives et
chine les gens les animaux de plus de
succès qu eva joly en tous les cas pour
le moment mais bon on a entendu parler
d' eva joly quand elle a dit à corinne
lepage je m'emmerde je veux dire non
mais voilà non mais c'est quand même fou
on est là
c'est un propos spontanée comme je vais
vous elle vous énerve un peu non non on
peut d'abord alors en fait est ce que
vous dit pas quel que soit le score on
s'en fout puisque de toute façon on a
signé un accord avec le parti socialiste
et qu'on aura des sièges à l'assemblée
nationale est ce que finalement vous
jouez pas à placer
non ça c'est ça fait 36 ans je suis en
france on l'a fait dès la première année
où toutes les viandes la corée du sud
pour marquer les places et je suis
obligée de vous la faire non mais
sérieusement vous n'avez pas peur que
les socialistes nous proposer des sièges
ils vous proposent des chaises pliantes
moi j'ai
la chance de connaître et martine aubry
et françois hollande ce sont des gens
très respectueux des accords et la
parole donnée donc j'ai pas d'inquiétude
par rapport au volet vol électoral gens
voulaient donner monsieur non mais c'est
pas qu'ils vont donner c'est qu'il ya un
accord il faut le respecter mais si les
françaises et les français veulent qu'il
y ait d'écologie des cinq prochaines
années malgré tout il faut donner un
rapport de france au premier tour en
faveur de la candidate des écologistes
et c'est aussi pour cette raison là
qu'il faut voter pour eva joly qu'on
écologistes ce prochain 22 avril j'avais
entendu
agents bonsoir ya plein de gens qui sont
en train de se dire
mais je connais cette fille ou gelée vu
déjà lors président que j'ai bien la
fofolle qu'on a vu depuis des années à
la télé présenté des caméras cachées un
peu trash est très marrante des trucs
comme ça
[Musique]
voilà jason mesdames messieurs je
l'envers alors donc votre spectacle
s'appelle sous les pavés les pavés mais
non pas sous les pavés la plage alors
vous racontez votre éducation par les
parents 68 a alors on peut dire que
votre énoncé il avait de castro vous
êtes la fille de roland castro donc
ainsi tech urbanistes maoïste bien connu
vous connaissez roland castro chef
allemand bien c'est quelqu'un roland
castro arriveront intéressant mais
vigoureux impertinente comme il faut
être il s'est présenté à la
présidentielle pour le mouvement de
l'utopie concrète en 2007 en votre mère
c'est margot féministe révolutionnaire
établi en milieu ouvrier en 1968 alors
évidement vous avez une enfance assez
bohème non une enfance on considère un
peu les enfants comme des adultes
ou le slogan il est interdit d'interdire
est en fait une façon de justifier qu'on
ne faut rien dans l'éducation des
encombrements une adolescence déconneuse
des études interrompues des petits jobs
mon but j'ai quand même eu des diplômes
bon donner quoi comme diplôme une
licence d'études cinématographiques
d'accord et donc en 2001 vous barre à
los angeles pour prendre des cours de
comédie vous faites serveuse bon là et
là vous tombez sur un producteur de
blockbusters way qui avait deux chiens
vous entendiez bien avec lui je
m'entendais bien avec lui puis à la fin
je m'entendais mieux avec ses chiens
ouais
et un jour donc il apprend qui est votre
père et gulli ton père est communiste
mais ça va être très très dur pour moi
ouais j'ai arrêté net votre relation là
bas en fait les histoires d'amour à
longue distance de toute façon on prend
un avion oui c'est vrai qu'avec douze
heures d'avion à chaque fois oui donc je
vais laisser tomber bah ouais alors dans
le spectacle évidemment on parler de
votre père par exemple javier pas le
droit de faire de blagues non non si
justement en plus je pense qu on
communiquait beaucoup par la blague hein
pas par deux choses normales vraiment
normes et de parents et d'enfants avec
mon père en fait je raconte dans le
spectacle comment j'ai eu des
difficultés à communiquer avec mon père
qui s'intéressait un peu qu à la
politique et à lui même
non mais enfin ouais voilà il avait du
mal mais en fait je me rendais compte
que je me suis rendu compte après que
lui aussi avait fait parce qu'il avait
beaucoup de mal à communiquer avec
les enfants pas alors un jour vous dites
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai envie d'être
[ __ ] et ils vous disent finalement tu
pourrais être [ __ ] c'est pas un problème
quoi c'est ça l'éducation des 68 ans en
fait c'est que qui me disait tu me faut
vraiment l'important dans ta vie tu peux
faire ce que tu veux mais il faut que tu
sois libre est ce que vous regrettez
aujourd'hui finalement d'avoir été élevé
par des parents soixante huitard pas du
tout justement je pense qu'à être
traduites s'est elle non plus angoissés
par an il marche seul spectacle ouais ça
marche bien ça marche bien on est
content peau
on passe maintenant à l'actualité de la
semaine avec l'édito de blacko un essai
françois d'orcival président du comité
éditoriale de valeurs actuelles que nous
retrouverons sur ce plateau après le
magnéto
[Musique]
ou françois hollande taxer les plus
riches ce n'est pas une mesure d'ordre
économique c'est une mesure d'ordre
moral c'est pas une question de
rendement c'est une question de
moralisation après son vibrant herman
contre le paiement de la finance le
révérend père hollande poursuit sa
croisade contre l'argent s'il est élu
promis les gentils smicard seront
récompensés et les méchants riches
seront punis
méchants patrons du cac 40 ont augmenté
leurs salaires de 30 4% en 2010 contre
seulement 2 4% d'augmentation pour les
gentils smicards vous trouvez ça juste
si le père hollande écouté son coeur il
distribuerait de l'argent aux gentils
smicard mais les caisses sont vides
alors du goût qui a décidé d'être deux
fois plus sévère avec les méchants
riches tous ceux dont le salaire dépasse
100 fois le smic seront punis vous posez
la tête sur le billot et vous vous levez
votre vin compris
le père hollande a promis de taxer à 75
% des revenus qui dépassent le million
d'euros annuels s'il est élu les riches
devront faire pénitence et jamais
l'heure est grave nouvelle tranche
d'impôt pour les revenus supérieurs à
150 mille euros la faune mans des niches
fiscales et du quotient familial
augmentation des droits de succession et
de lier cette taxation du patrimoine qui
dans ticket celle du travail
en plus ils n'auront même plus de
bouclier fiscal pour se protéger du coup
on les entends déjà crier au martyre
mais qui va les plaindre en france il ya
16 millions et demi de salariés la
moitié d'entre eux gagnent moins de 1700
euros net par mois alors les problèmes
fiscaux les 3000 français les plus
riches ne devrait pas attendrir grand
monde bien sûr si tous les riches
quittent la france se fait un mauvais
calcul économique mais la morale ce
n'est pas fait pour rapporter de
l'argent c'est fait pour rapporter des
doigts du coup ce qui paraît être un
mauvais calcul économique se révélera
peut-être un excellent calcul électoral
voilà c'était l'édito de blacko un mise
en image de julien grave françois
d'orcival bonsoir bonsoir êtres vivants
du comité éditorial éditorialiste à
valeurs actuelles bienvenue parmi nous
alors au dessus d'un million d'euros par
an le taux d'imposition devra être de
75% a déclaré françois hollande dans
l'émission paroles de français lundi
soir sur tf1 leur attention c'est pas
75% sur un million c'est 75% sur ce qui
dépasse un million voilà alors
commençons est ce que vous trouvez cette
mesure juste et je trouve qu'il est
indispensable que nous révisions notre
système fiscal qui fait beaucoup trop
pour les très riches et beaucoup trop
peu pour être très pauvres vous allez
payer les 75% là parce que vous êtes
beaucoup de pognon et votre bouquin et
aucun aucun espoir j'ai pas de droit
d'auteur par conséquent jamais
totalement égal que ça paraisse à 4 vous
avez rien toucher sur indignez-vous nord
n'ont pas à chaud je n'aime pas les
droits d'auteur je suis un vieux
diplomate avec une bonne retraite
j'aime vivre de ma retraite j'ai fais
toi de l'argent il ya les loups l'argent
l'argent est distribué à des
organisations utile bravo du nord
presque trouvé sa juste vous jean
vincent je crois que ça va dans la bonne
direction dans notre programme brute
vous pouvez sourire ça ne m'étonne pas
nous nous avions dit qu'au-delà de
150000 euros on pourrait passer à une
tranche de 60 % et au delà de 500 mille
euros une tranche de 77 palois nohlan
parce que essayé d'expliquer dans ce
pays que ce serait scandaleux parce
qu'on aurait dit ce qu'ils partiraient
peut-être en suisse qu'à un million de
badauds a plus de confiance de robert je
vous l'avais dit comme vous l'avez dit
c'est juste la tranche au-delà du
million d'euros à l'afrique il leur
resterait oh là là pour vivre par an
peut-être 600 ou 700 mille euros par an
c'est vrai que à ce stade là les les
difficultés commencent à poindre dans la
vie quotidienne alors avant de passer à
françois d'orcival le suspense continue
jason vous trouvez ça bien d'où ça vient
mais je suis pas concerné donc
vous êtes nombreux à m quand vous
trouvez ça bien vrai ça juste oui bien
lent françois l'impôt il est toujours
juste quand c'est pour les autres et ça
c'est le principe de base françois
hollande il vous dit 75% pour faire
mieux que vous qui dites 70 plus la csg
quand même oublier la csg donc c'est 8%
donc c'est 75 + 8 égale 83 pourquoi pas
dire 100 % en quoi en quoi ça gênerait
de dire 100% parce que maintenant la loi
déjà dit et voilà avant 80 avant reagan
aux etats-unis c'était 80 % des loyers
aux états unis des dangereux et shiloh
schiste ou s'ils entendent avant que
reagan n'arrive alors françois hollande
il est donc entre les verts et le
mélange est donc vous voulez
et on est loin de service public silva
dit vous voulez vous dire ce à quoi vous
dédiez vous savez très bien et hollande
vole dit ça va rapporter quelques
dizaines de millions d'euros et hollande
vous dis même lui-même ce n'est pas une
affaire économique effectivement et ça
ne rapporte rien donc c'est du symbole
mais le symbole ça signifie que quand
vous êtes riche et que vous êtes en
france normalement vous devez être
accompagné par un arrêté d'expulsion
les gars vous êtes riche vous sortez on
vous reconnaît à l'affronter mais c'est
ça le bouclier je crois que il ya 200 ou
300 grandes fortunes référencés en
suisse voyez-vous et dans les quatre
années sous sarkozy s'est passé de 17
français à 5,44 français donc vous voyez
bien que on peut faire tout ce qu'on
veut ce qu'ils décident d'aller se faire
imposer ailleurs ils le font et c'est là
bien là parce que c'est en chanson les
grands discours patriotique des années
des zones y est que je vois qu'ils se
barrent payer les impôts en suisse et
c'est assez scandaleux qu'on voit les
difficultés qu'on a sur la santé
l'éducation et même la police dans ce
pays bas voilà mais c'est aussi un
moment une question de patriotisme et
vous pourrez faire ce que vous voulez si
à un moment donné pas un petit signal en
disant quand même c'est assez simple et
riche il faut qu'ils payent un peu vous
pouvez pas mais compliqué vous entend
faire qu'une paix comment voulez-vous il
sauver les démarches qu'on est plus aisé
il n'aide pas les plus aisés vers ceux
là ne dit pas c'est que les riches
paient déjà une boutique toi qui ne
payent pas c'est pareil enfin là où tout
à l'heure monsieur hessel a dit quelque
chose de très juste
thierry ardisson lui dit et vous vous
êtes millionnaire en droit d'auteur
monsieur hessel dit non je ne touche pas
à mes droits d'auteur
quel est le juge finale en matière de
richesse c'est à quoi consacrez-vous
cette richesse qu'est ce que vous en
faites est ce que vous en faites de la
jouissance ou bien ce que vous
l'investissent et ou bien est ce que
vous créez d'autres richesses ou bien
est ce que vous créez des emplois etc
tout dépend de ce que vous en faites
enfin cette conception qui consiste à
dire c'est un riche donc c'est un [ __ ]
mais c'est quand même incroyable cette
histoire sont des [ __ ] des saisies
jeu ce qui peut vivre avec un peu moins
et tout quels sont les fleurons de la
france aujourd'hui notamment les
industries du luxe alors ce que vous
voulez vous c'est que l'industrie du
luxe soit entièrement achetés par les
émirs ça sape tout va vous êtes d'accord
c'est l'argent qui vient où le froid
j'ai donc ça va donc vous seriez
d'accord sur le fait qu'il y ait par
exemple une augmentation du taux d'impôt
sur les sociétés lorsque l'argent va
dans les bonus dont les dividendes
plutôt que quand il est réinvesti
l'entreprise pour faire de l'emploi
industriel mais non non je ne suis pas
d'accord voilà le mot de la fin stéphane
c'est vrai que ces deux conceptions du
monde qui s'affrontent alors je dirais
si vous voulez petite conclusion du lieu
du vieil ambassadeurs que nous avons
besoin de sortir d'une crise qui est une
crise du capitalisme dérégulé et qui
existent malheureusement depuis sa chair
et reagan et qui continuent à peser sur
nous il faut réguler le marché et le
capitalisme et nous en sommes
malheureusement en france très loin
voilà en tous les cas hollande dit là il
a fait son pourquoi
il a beau être un peu fou qu est ce quoi
c'est un petit coup la politique est
faite de symboles je pense que c'est
bien bon sens avec eux il est allé à
londres pour dire à la communauté
française de londres je ne suis pas
dangereux oui je ne suis pas dangereux
donc ne croyez quand même pas tout ce
que je dis
le coup de pied de l'âne ça s'appelle
bien on continue à discuter de
l'actualité de la semaine avec les
vitaux de blacko 2
[Musique]
les français sont déçus par la campagne
six sur dix trouvent qu'il est de
mauvaise qualité faut dire qu'au lieu
d'échangé des arguments en ce moment les
candidats échanges surtout d insulte aux
morts
soir si on vient me chercher pour me
troupe d'écolo m fonctionne à plein tube
tout ça c'est du cinéma une campagne
électorale c'est pas une promenade de
santé ne serait-il pas temps que la
campagne retrouve un peu de dignité le
problème c'est que plus le débat digne
plus il devient chiant bah oui il suffit
de regarder les audiences bonsoir le
face-à-face fillon aubry sur france 2 a
été suivi par 3 millions six cent mille
personnes en revanche quand les
invectives et la violence remplace le
combat d'idées l'un ça cartonne servait
absolument pas rien ni au premier ni au
deuxième tour le match mélenchon le pen
a été suivi par 5 millions de
téléspectateurs on voit bien que ce
débat était organisé uniquement pour une
logique commerciale alors pas étonnant
que les journaux parce qu'à part belle à
la polémique
pourtant certains journaux essaie
d'organiser le débat d'idées le 18
février par exemple le parisien publie
une interview exclusive d'henri guaino
qui donne sa vision de la france et bien
ses propos suscitent 96 réactions de
lecteurs en revanche quatre jours plus
tard qu'en guaino s'énerve sur le
plateau d'une télé régionale ça va être
un portable à la fin et de retard les
oui cette fois l'article du parisien va
susciter 292 réaction sans compter le
buzz dans les autres médias pareil pour
eva joly quand elle parle d'écologie ça
plombe l'ambiance quand elle insulte
corinne lepage ça fait le buzz corinne
lepage qui dit que vous désertez la
promesse écologique vous l'aurez voulu
dit quoi corinne lepage
la merde du coup la victime devient une
stratégie pour occuper l'espace
médiatique en janvier 56% des français
ne savait pas qui était najet belkacem
lorsqu'elle a comparé sarkozy un produit
de contrebande imaginé par des cerveaux
d'extrême droite la porte-parole de
hollande a créé une polémique qui va lui
faire gagner quelques points de
notoriété en fait quand les français
réclament du débat d'idées faut surtout
pas les croire
87 % d'entre eux estiment que l' affaire
dsk a été surmédiatisée n'empêche ils
étaient plus de 14 millions devant tf1
pour se repaître de ces confessions
intimes en toute dignité et bien sûr
voilà c'était l'édito de blako de mise
en images de juniac gras voilà alors en
penser que vu la crise la campagne
allait prendre un peu de hauteur on
pensait qu'on avait parlé de loro du
triple à de l'europe de la
mondialisation
résultat comme d'hab' c'est un concours
de petites phrases un combat de catch
alors est ce que comme six français sur
dix vous êtes déçus par la campagne
stéphane hessel je considère que la
campagne n'a pas encore atteint ses
véritables objectifs
je fais confiance à ceux qui s'y emploie
actuellement les équipes qui entoure les
candidats et qui peuvent j'espère dans
les jours qui viennent doit elle donner
quelque chose de plus intéressant à
mastiquer
oiseaux bajard faisons que c'est un peu
toujours pareil finalement pendant une
campagne il ya comme c'est comme si on
parlait même moins de politique
qu'avant avant il veut
plus de fonds même si je sais vraiment
pas plus de la crise
sur 100 soit vous êtes déçus par cette
campagne écoutez je suis d'accord avec
mélenchon quand il dit qu une campagne
présidentielle ce n'est pas une
promenade de santé
ça c'est toujours le cas ensuite à
mesure que l'on s'approche de l'échéance
on voit bien que les candidats sont
pressé de s'expliquer sur un certain
nombre de points essentiels qu'ils sont
amenés à 6 explique est de plus en plus
et par conséquent à se répondre et c'est
ce que je crois qui est l'utilité et
l'intérieur n'est la main quand sarkozy
en est là on se répandent toute la
journée oui enfin la conclusion oui
c'est le jour de l'élection en 2007
j'imagine que à deux mois de l'élection
dont on aurait pu dire exactement la
même chose et on a eu 85 % de
participation à l'élection
présidentielle ça veut dire que le
citoyen s'est déplacé il y aura cette
fois nicolas sarkozy est très
probablement ce duel entre sarkozy et
hollande nous verrons si la mobilisation
est là même bien françois d'orcival
merci d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
le titre de votre dernier livre qui
s'appelle l'elysée fantômes les années
noires qui robert laffont merci beaucoup
voilà c'était la p2 slt on se retrouve
après la pub avec le zapping guillon est
notre invité du samedi 20 heures ce soir
caroline foire aux photographes et
compagne de gilles jacquet de grand
reporter de france 2 tués en syrie a
tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
oui
bonsoir matériel bonsoir était rien nous
sommes toujours en compagnie de stéphane
hessel
jean vincent placé
et jason
et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir caroline poiron
bonsoir
alors caroline le 11 janvier dernier la
france apprenait avec stupeur la mort de
gilles jacquier grand reporter à france
télévisions emporté par un tir de
mortier dans la ville de homs en syrie
caroline vous êtes photographe
professionnel vous étiez la compagne de
gilles vous avez eu deux petites filles
ensemble et vous étiez avec lui en syrie
au moment du drame vous nous raconter
votre histoire à 20 heures en attendant
j'accueille stéphane guillon
c'est mon cher stéphane ça va tu peux
dire que le réalisateur de l'émission
didier froehly a été fait chevalier des
arts et des lettres cette semaine voilà
incroyable avoue stéphane pour guy
randonnée de tous
[Musique]
un site internet a annoncé la mort de
nicolas sarkozy dans un accident de la
route c'était une connerie alors c'était
une connerie tant que le président ne se
trouve pas sur la route de nadine morano
ils risquent rien
déclaration de najat belkacem porte
parole de françois hollande le nicolas
sarkozy qu'on cherche à vendre au
français est un faux une contrefaçon
ah non non non sarkozy c'est pas une
contrefaçon c'est un vrai produit de
qualité sans gouvernement pareil claude
guéant c'est de la super calmes si vous
êtes à la recherche d'un discours bien
racistes sur la violence des comoriens
la délinquance des roms font prendre du
guéant marine le pen et claude guéant et
or se sont pâmés contrefaçon
[Applaudissements]
le pakistan a achevé de raser la maison
de ben laden oui enfin quand même quand
même ben laden question démolition
c'était quand même le meilleur
[Musique]
du guillon légumes selon le canard
enchaîné
ikea a fait appel à une société de
sécurité pour espionner ses salariés et
ses clients ah c'est pas bien ça c'est
pas bien est-ce que nous quand on achète
des meubles à à monter des bacs de
rangement de la vaisselle est ce qu on
demande la fiche de renseignements
d'ingvar kamprad le créateur d'ikea non
est ce que ça nous intéresse de savoir
qu'il a eu des sympathies néo nazis est
ce que quand on achète un casier à
chaussettes on a besoin de savoir que
campera net et membre de l'équivalent
des jeunesses hitlériennes en suède non
et qu'il était pote avec le chef des néo
nazisme et doit
on achète notre casier sans poser de
questions
[Applaudissements]
dans la lutte contre l'homophobie
villepin prône l'ouverture aux autres
il va très très loin en ce moment
dominique très loin trop loin
[Applaudissements]
accusé par corinne lepage de déserter la
promesse écologique eva joly répond je
l'en merde attention attention c'est de
la merde 100% bio sans engrais sans
pesticides c'est une bonne mère viennent
chez nous abbas de compost de purin
d'ortie ça refoule ça fouette mais c'est
que du bon
[Applaudissements]
monsieur placez vous confirmez c'est une
merde 100% bio 100% bio
pesticides c'est bien cette photo
le vaccin antigrippe moins efficace
cette année déjà 3 millions de malades
ouais cette fois-ci roselyne s'en fout
dans deux mois à les parties alors les
personnes âgées les bébés
les vieux peuvent crever
roselyne s'en fout
la prison de la santé va être
entièrement rénové cellule individuelle
le toit panoramique
restaurants ouverts aux visiteurs
c'était indispensable et il le fallait
et le fallait en juin tous les copains
de sarkozy mise en examen pourraient
être incarcérés eric woerth le juge
courroye nicolas bazire ils sont
habitués aux honneurs aux ors de la
république il leur faut un minimum de
confort
[Applaudissements]
carla bruni rêve de participer à
l'émission de frédéric lopez rendez vous
en terre inconnue
c'est françois bayrou qui devrait
participer à terre inconnue on n'en
mènerait à l'elysée
alors là je suis avec monsieur bayrou au
coeur du pouvoir dans le salon des
tapisseries situé entre le vestibule
d'honneur et le salon murat un lieu de
toute beauté resterait sous la
présidence de félix faure ça fait quoi
françois bayrou devenir dans un endroit
où vous n'avez aucune chance de vous
installer un jour
suite à un nouvel accident à bord d'un
bateau de la société costa croisières
d'anciens employés de la compagnie
dénonce une atmosphère total de débauche
à bord corruption drogue alcool et
prostitution ben oui mais bon bon quand
on sait qu'on risque de mourir échoué
sur une côte ou brûlés en plein coeur de
l'océan indien perdu pour perdu autant
prendre de la drogue se bourrer la
gueule laisse tirer des [ __ ]
celle là elle va vous plaire la dernière
elle est pour
bientôt création du premier hamburger
expérimental fabriqué des cellules
souches ces cellules extraites des
muscles d'un squelette de bovins sont
ensuite cultivé dans du sérum foetale de
vaud agrémenter le tout avec des frites
faites à base de pomme de terre ogm de
la marque comme flora très utilisés pour
la confection de la pâte à papier
arrosez le tout d'un coca cola l'acide
phosphorique pour brûler le foetus de
vaud et la pâte à papier pour déguster
le tout choisissez un fast food en
bordure de périphérique manger de la
merde c'est aussi en respirer très bon
appétit à tous
sur canalplus.fr on passe maintenant à
notre invité du samedi 20 heures
[Musique]
car une robe en soir bonsoir vous n'êtes
ni le 6 septembre
1973 à tour père homme d'affaires dans
l'agroalimentaire mère femme au foyer
et votre enfant s'est placée sous le
signe des tribulations professionnels de
votre père à 9 ans vous débarquez aux
états unis à saint louis vous habitez
pendant six ans c'est là que pour votre
neuvième anniversaire vos parents vous
offre un appareil photo et vous réalisez
votre premier reportage sur les noirs
pauvres vous dites j'ai photographié ce
que je ne connaissais pas et finalement
ce sera toute votre vie effectivement
samassa m'a poursuivie jusqu'à présent
ouais et vous continuez toujours en
cherchant à photographier
l'inconnu les oublier oui enfin aller à
la rencontre des gens s'assoient dans
l'est dans les personnes âgées les
personnes attendaient mali these moeurs
sont trois ans pour le faire alors j'ai
effectué une bonne scolarité vous avez
votre bac b à 18 ans vous hésitez pour
savoir quelles études supérieures vous
allez faire mais c'est un voyage en
australie qui va décider de votre
vocation vous photographier des
aborigènes et quand vous rentrez vous
décidé d'apprendre votre métier de
photographe au centre iris oui alors à
26 ans vous débutez votre carrière vous
réalisez ce qui vous intéresse t à
l'histoire en train de se faire vous
dites je voulais être dans l'événement
j'ai parcouru en fait la steppe mongole
pour aller à la rencontre des cadres
boucan en russie il se trouve au dessus
de tchétchénie c'était mon premier sujet
voilà sur du long terme et c'est vrai
qu'après j'ai je me suis plus intéressé
à la géopolitique le liban l'afghanistan
mais c'est à nantes
bizarrement que vous rencontrerez gilles
jacquier vous tombez amoureux l'un de
l'autre et vous décidez de partir en
afghanistan lui fait un sujet pour
envoyé spécial sur les femmes qui se
font aspergée d'acide par les talibans
et vous sur les écoles de jeunes filles
qui sont incendiées par les mêmes
talibans on m'a trahi ensemble sur scène
alors retour vous emménagez ensemble et
bientôt naîtront vos deux jumelles
quand les révolutions arabes commencent
vous partez tous les deux sur le terrain
voilà les filles ont quatre mois ouais
vous partie de tous les deux ce qui est
assez rare parce qu'en général
il ya toujours dans les coupes comme ça
où il y en a un qui est photographe
l'autre est souvent sédentaires disons
tel départ des notes rampante ans et
plus ont ces pactes et en décembre 2011
vous partez tout seul en syrie et vous
allez à homs dans le fameux quartier
alaouite de bab amro sous la protection
de l'armée syrienne libre qui en fait
est un nombre de passeurs qui qui
permettent aux journalistes de te
rentrer dans france alors là évidemment
vous passez par le liban ou fête les 25
kilomètres qui séparent le liban de deux
hommes c'est dans des conditions
absolument incroyable aussi bien à
l'aller qu'au retour d'ailleurs c'est
très très difficile ah oui oui et des
rivières parce que des champs d'oliviers
parce qu'il faut passer une maison
maison prendre des motos faire passer
les sacs avant peut-être ensuite
traversé des autoroutes avant le camion
pas après pour pas être repérés passé
dans les tranchées est arrivé à rampe
donc sur le couvrir nang et on est de la
chance d'arriver
au bout d'un jour à rome mais on est en
rentrant on a mis trois jours un long
retour vous raconter à gilles ce que
vous avez vécu et au site où vous
décidez d'y retourner ensemble officiel
alors le 7 janvier 2012 de terry c'est à
damas alors première surprise la douane
refuse de vous laisser passer alors que
vous aviez un visa on avait un visage
quinze jours ils nous ont donné quelques
uns de quatre jours c'est là
qu'intervient un personnage central
diplomatie syrienne la fameuse soeur
agnès est une religieuse franco
libanaise qui est une intermédiaire
entre le gouvernement syrien et les
journalistes étrangers c'est grâce à
elle finalement vous pouvez rentrer son
appel à une facilitatrice c'est
quelqu'un qui a à sept contacts rien que
par sa présence sans montrer de papier
peut faire que la douane nous laisse pas
ses heures à damas cette soeur agnès
s'occupe de tous enfin vous fait surtout
faire du tourisme
puisque visite dans les souks la messe
enfin des choses pas très passionnante
j'imagine pour vous ce que nous on
voulait c'est d'avoir déjà l'entretien
une entretien avec bachar al assad
pour la télévision française et pour
paris match on voulait vous rencontrez
des businessman voir un peu comment
aider l'économie vu les gels des avoirs
par exemple le lendemain sera nièce vous
propose de partir pour rome
c'était pas prévu en fait au départ mais
elle insiste lourdement effectivement ce
soir là elle a insisté pour qu'on vienne
et
gilles ne voulais pas y aller il a
décidé de rester à damas ainsi que
christophe son cameraman et moi même et
en fait mais rania ça a été assez
menaçante disant que si on a les parents
ont été
expulsés en fait voilà alors non
seulement elle vous demande instamment
d'y aller en plus elle ne part pas avec
vous et surtout elle vous demande de
signer une décharge de responsabilité en
disant quoi qu'il vous arrive là bas
sera pas de la faute du gouvernement
syrien voilà tout à fait avec la charte
de munich on devait signer aussi oui
tout à fait alors là vous partez avec un
convoi d'une vingtaine de journalistes
étrangers vous arrivez à homs à 14h30 et
là on vous dit il faut se dépêcher faut
se dépêcher parce que les bombardements
commence à 15h dans une demi heure
exactement alors déjà sur la route on
n'était pas à protéger on avait pas
d'armes armée avec mon but alors qu'il
faut savoir que la route est très très
dangereuse donc on est arrivé à rome
14h30 effectivement hélas vite dans les
voitures on nous dit il faut absolument
la seule chose qu'on peut faire en une
demi heure c'est rencontrer des gens
dans la rue et aussi ensuite tout de
suite allé à l'hôpital voilà l hôpital
pour se mettre à l'abri des
bombardements mais curieusement les
chauffeurs vous emmène dans la direction
opposée de l'hôpital ouais mais on ne
savait pas à ce moment là alors 500
mètres plus loin vous tombez sur une
manifestation la gloire de bachar el
assad
les journalistes sortent pour filmer et
un obus tombent à 100 m 2
la première déflagration a eu lieu il
était 15 heures ouais alors les
manifestants pro bachar el-assad pousse
les journalistes vers un immeuble dans
la même direction que la zone de
l'impact du premier obus et vu que
certains au caméraman a été déjà parti
gilles a vu son caméraman de partir il
est parti moi j'ai suivi un
deuxième tir sur une école qui est en
face de l'immeuble où vous êtes réfugiés
troisième tir gilles et vous vous hisser
sur le toit mais à ce moment là gilles
voit son caméraman christophe toujours
en bas ils se font signer ce voyage
était derrière je filme et gilles il se
voit on ne redescend premier étage est
là gilles me dit j'étais sans chercher
christophe donc jacques s de la tête et
c'est là que la 4e déflagration est est
tombé et c'est là que j'ai entendu
gillet touché je suis descendu sa durée
40 secondes et j'ai vu j la terre sous
les escaliers a battu à mort
il était en fait il est mort sur le coup
et en fait il est tombé dans les bras de
mireille qui fête cet été sa traductrice
qui l'a déposé à terre qui est parti à
l'hôtel sans même un regard c'est là que
je l' ai vu et c'est là que je les prie
et j'ai fait deux trois photos et on l'a
emmené dans le taxi pour un hôpital
un hôpital de campagne mais voilà on
considère aujourd'hui comme des mouroirs
voilà quand même très bizarre cette
histoire quoi c'est un guet-apens c'est
un guet-apens et un scénario de ces
traîtres tout et tout est scénarisé
quand on est sur la place qu'on ait un
terrain train d'interviewer des gens on
voit des femmes des hommes se balader
son manteau en rigolant pratiquement
s'embrassant dans un pays musulman ça ne
lui fait pas maintenant c'est vrai qu'il
ya des choses qui sont incertaines on a
la preuve de pas grand chose mais pour
que pour que je dise que c'est un
scénario c'est que le mortier si c'est
un âne et un mortier il a été envoyé de
6 km donc il faut ajuster le tir 1 sur
un immeuble il faut ajuster le tir et
surtout il faut l'avoir prévu avant
certain éveil pourquoi il ya eu un
mortier tombés dans l'école la veille on
c'est pas tout ça mais il faut savoir
que ça ne s'improvise pas lu je suis un
guet-apens quel mobile l'idée c'était
faire peur aux journalistes l'idée
c'était de nous montrer qu'il y avait
des terroristes et que ces terroristes
la tuer
la population
et les civils et malheureusement gill a
subi
un est mort aujourd'hui un mois et demi
après le drame c'est toujours sur le
shop vous dites je tiens debout grâce à
mes enfants
vous dites lorsqu'on est journaliste de
guerre qu'on sait que ces choses là
peuvent arriver on pense qu'elles vont
jamais arrivé
sert quand on connaît des risques et
aujourd'hui je ne pleure pas la mort de
gil pour ça en fait je le pleure je
pleure la mort de j pour dota d'un tas
d'autres raisons mais on connaissait les
risques qu'ils connaissaient les risques
il savait ce qu'il faisait une
consolation c'est que vous étiez avec
lui quand c'est arrivé
est-ce que journalistes doivent
continuer à aller à homs oui moi je
pense mais il faut pas non plus se
précipiter les choses vont on veut pas
non plus se terminer demain
merci de votre témoignage car
voilà
grave épisode
[Applaudissements]
deux enfants avec way et voir mon visage
mouillé
voilà c'était salut les terriens votre
taux plus samedi avec stéphane hessel
pour le rescapé l'exil chez ton
quichotte jean vincent placé sénateur de
l'essonne président du comité de
campagne d'eva joly jason qu'on retrouve
tous les lundis et tous les revenus à
l'espace salle de noël avec son
spectacle sous les pavés des pavés
françois d'orcival de l'heure actuelle
et caroline voir merci beaucoup je vous
signale le concert des hommes note la
section ville de gréement le 9 mars à
l'aîné
rideau fille merci à tous ceux qui m'ont
aidé à faire cette émission je voudrais
groland point qu'on est pour les abonnés
à 20h50 wang les jeunes bac à glaçons
john f rendez vous samedi prochain
et d'ici là ils sont canalplus.fr avec 9
des vagues l'édito des gréements l'élite
plaquant salut les terriens
les corrections de ne rien rater de
inhabituel abonnez vous il m'était
impossible